welcome to Horace's the channel will be
discussed the latest tech news and of
into the newest tech products so today
we're taking a look at why you shouldn't
buy a GPU even if GPU prices hit MSRP
but before we delve into that make sure
to hit that subscribe button if you guys
would like to stay updated with the
latest tech news related to gaming and
pcs so as you guys already know GPU
prices have been inflated for quite a
while now because of a variety of
reasons such as cryptocurrency mining
boom increased demand stock shortages
and inflated RAM prices however
fortunately GPU prices across the board
have been slowly going down for the last
several weeks and many GPUs are even
hitting MSRP some GPUs can even be found
below MSRP like the GTX 1080 which you
can find right now for $500 with a game
bundled with it and this is not just
true for the GTX 1080
right now you can get a GTX 1060 EVGA 6
gigabyte card for $250 on Amazon and if
you get to re catch on $250 is the MSRP
for the gtx 1066 gigabyte card so as you
guys can see GPU price across the board
are finally hitting MSRP and the cards
that have hit MSRP will hit MSRP in the
next couple of weeks
so why shouldn't you take advantage of
this situation and buy a graphics card
right now
well here's the thing it's not really an
advantage first of all the 10 series is
over 2 years old so why would you buy a
GPU that is over 2 years old for a full
price and on top of that the 1100 series
from Nvidia is coming really soon
so these GPUs are going to be outdated
as well so why would you pay full price
for them you couldn't have gotten the
same exact GPU for the same price two
years ago probably even less you may be
like well for the last couple months GPU
prices have been so high the MSRP is a
lot more favorable and to this you have
to remember that just because you're
getting ripped off for less doesn't mean
that you're not getting ripped off stone
overall the 10th series and the rx 500
series from AMD are nearing the end of
the
life cycle and it makes no sense to pay
full MSRP price for either of them
furthermore the gtx 1100 series is
coming up very soon and it will most
likely be offered for the same MSRP as
its 10 seriously equivalents for example
the 11 60 will be offered at the same
MSRP s2 1060 and 1170 will be offered at
the same MSR fps the 1070 and so on and
so forth so as a result in just a couple
of months you can get the 1100 series
equivalent of the car that you were
looking at right now for the same price
that you're willing to spend right now
and by getting the 1100 series of
equivalent of the 10 series card instead
of the 10 series card itself you are
getting a significant performance
upgrade you'll be on the Tal and
animator process and you will get GTR 6
memory and much more so by waiting just
a couple of months for the same price
that you're willing to spend right now
you can get a lot lot more so it really
makes no sense to buy a graphics card
right now for MSRP so by now I hope that
it's really clear why you shouldn't get
a 10 Series card for MSRP but what if
there's a really killer deal on a 10
series graphics card should you buy a
dent well in my opinion you should still
just wait for the 1100 series because
again it'll provide you with much more
performance for the same price for
example the GTX 1160 is expected to
perform just barely better than the gtx
1070 so let's say you find a killer deal
for the gtx 1070 and it is being offered
for the same MSRP as the gtx 1066
gigabyte card at $250 first of all it is
really really unlikely that you're gonna
find such a great deal but even if you
did waiting for the 1160 and buying that
for $250 would be the better option
because of all the perks that comes with
like Judy our sixth memory at 12
nanometer process and just simple
bragging rights that you're on the
newest platform well what if you don't
care about getting more performance and
all you care about is the price
performance ratio even here it would be
smarter to wait for the gtx 1100 series
and then make decisions because when the
gtx 1100 series comes out the 10th
series will drop even more in price so
you'll get an even bed
price to performance ratio finally I
know that many of you guys have been
waiting for a very long time right now
so why wouldn't you just make the whole
weight worth it now why would you give
in right now by getting a GPU for full
MSRP or just at a good deal but the GPU
is still gonna be outdated very soon
instead you guys should just make the
whole weight worth it by getting a new
1100 series card when it comes out over
all right now it really makes no sense
to buy any GPU at MSRP because the GPUs
are going to be outdated very soon and
even if you find a good deal the 1100
series will most likely beat the
performance to price very sure that you
will be getting with the card that
you're considering right now the only
scenario where it makes sense to buy a
GPU right now instead of waiting is the
gtx 980ti
because the 1180 is not gonna really
beat it out by that much and the gtx
1180 TI isn't coming out for a long time
so that's probably the most reasonable
one out of all the GPUs available right
now however if you're considering to buy
a GTX 1080i then you probably want the
best performance available and all the
perks that come along with it so you
should probably just wait for the GTX at
1180 to be able to get GTD r6 memory and
be on a culinary process and much more
so as a result only buy a GPU right now
if you truly truly need it and don't buy
a GPU right now just because it is being
offered for MSRP and you can feel better
about yourself for not overpaying for
the GPU because you're still getting
ripped off it is clear that it has been
a rough couple of months for many of you
guys but I really recommend that you
guys just stick along and push through
and make it all worth it but that's just
what I think I know that you guys get
really angry whenever I tell you to wait
any longer so make sure to push all the
heat down below but seriously though how
do you guys feel about this do you guys
agree that it is not a very smart
decision to buy a GPU right now even if
GPU prices hit MSRP or do you think that
times couldn't be better to buy a GPU
make sure to comment down below what you
guys think because I do read all my
comments I'm curious as to what you guys
think - make sure to post your thoughts
also if you guys like this video and
agree then make sure drop a like and if
you guys hated it and
please disagreed and make sure drop a
dislike as well finally if you would
like to see more videos just like this
one then make sure to hit that subscribe
button but until next time bye
[Music]